welcome back so where we had left off we
said okay we have this angle here what
can we can we figure out if any of these
angles are equal to it well we know that
alternate interior angles on you know
this is a transverse this is a
transversal line right here and these
are parallel lines so we know alternate
interior so this is an interior and it's
alternate interiors here so we know that
equals they equal each other I'm not
gonna draw it yet because sometimes if
you forget alternate interior you could
just remember well corresponding angle
is equal to each other so you could say
that that angle is also equal to this
angle and then you can use opposite
angles again to kind of get back to the
alternate interior I'll show you in map
the great thing about math is it's good
for people who have trouble memorizing
things if you have to just memorize a
few things and then everything else just
kind of falls out of it but anyway so we
figured out that this angle is the same
as this angle right because they're
alternate interior angles and this is
its corresponding side and then finally
what about this angle here I'm going to
draw a triple angle one two three what
does that one equal to on this triangle
well same reason alternate interior
angles of two parallel lines and
remember dealers we can kind of make
this claim is because we've I told you
at the beginning that these are that
this line right here and this line right
here are parallel right otherwise you
couldn't make this claim but since they
are alternate interior we know that this
is the same angle all right so we now
have shown that these are similar
triangles and I didn't have to do all
three angles I could have just done two
and that should have been good enough
for you to know that they're similar
because if two are the same that the
third also has to be the same and now
let's see if we can use this information
to figure out our ratios so let's see
let's let's color the sides the the same
side as the angle so we don't get
confused so this side is the orange side
right
this side is the blue the sign is right
okay so we have everything color-coded
and it probably it might be confusing
you but but it's useful because as we'll
see these triangles are actually kind of
flipped so let's see what we can do so
we know we need to figure out this or
inside here so this orange side here
let's call it X so X x equals question
mark this or inside here corresponds to
this side here right because it's
opposite this angle which is equal to
this angle so they're opposite to the
same angle so that's how we know they
correspond to each other so we could say
X over six is equal to and now what
other sides do we know well we know this
side here we know this four side let me
do it in that color we know this side is
four and since we put X in the numerator
on the left hand side well and four is
in the same triangle as this X we're
trying to figure out well put 4 in the
numerator on the right hand side 4 over
what well what side corresponds to 4
what is opposite this this this angle
right here what's this angle right so
for the corresponding side of this side
is this side is five and now we can
solve X is equal we just multiply both
sides by six so you get 24 over 5x is
equal to 24 over five not too bad and
then we could we could even go further
we can now figure we could figure out
this side is right here this magenta
side let's call that I don't know why
not too creative here well Y corresponds
to this angle so Y corresponds to this
eight side right so we could do Y over
eight is equal to well we could do a
bunch of thing we could say four over
five or we could do 20 let's do four
over five because we can do 24 over five
over six
that's kind of confusing so we could
also do that
over four over five multiplied both
sides by 8 and you get y is equal to 8
times 4 is what 32 32 over 5 equal to 32
over 5 and the reason why I did this
example because I want to show you that
it's that you can't just eyeball that's
sometimes you can if you get good at it
but it's not always completely obvious
which sides correspond to which sides it
might have been tempting to say that I
don't know this side corresponds to this
side or that this side corresponds to
this side but you really have to pay
attention to which side kind of matches
up with which angles so any side that
matches up with a certain angle that
same angle in the other triangle
whatever side is opposite that that's
its corresponding side I use a lot of
words but hopefully I'm giving you if
you have a bit of an intuition let's do
another one
first let's take a triangle and prove to
ourselves that it is that the two
triangles are similar so let's say let's
say I like these parallel lines let me
do two parallel lines again and then
this time around draw let me draw
there's a line then there we go it's
kind of a neat exit well first I said
these are parallel lines so let me mark
them as such parallel lines so what we
want to do is we want to prove that this
triangle right here is similar to the
bigger triangle similar to this triangle
this is pretty interesting they actually
overlap right
so first of all do we know any angles
and the two triangles that equal each
other well sure they have this angle
they actually both share the same exact
angle in common right it's because the
two triangles overlap at that point so
what else can we figure out so let's see
I mean I don't to be tacky without any
colors but let's see so let's see we
have this angle with this angle here and
what other angles are equal to this
angle well we can use our parallel lines
and transversal love angle rules and or
theorems or whatever and figure it out
well this angle corresponds to what well
it corresponds to this angle since it's
equivalent and you got that from your
parallel lines right so these two are
the same and then finally if I have a
good color if I have this angle draw a
triple angle here same thing this
corresponding angle is going to be right
here so there we know all three angles
of this triangle are are are the same so
this is a similar triangle and so if we
knew if we knew that let's say we know
that this side right here I'll give you
a little trick question from here to
here is five and from here to here is
seven from here to here is let us say
from I don't know from here to here is
I'm gonna make a couple good number is
12 and from here to here is oh I don't
know let me think of a good it's let me
say nine let me say it's six and I
wanted to figure out what this is how do
we do that and I further made it more
confusing by adding all these squiggly
lines well we already know that these
are two similar triangles so we can use
that information to our ratios so if we
call
this is equal to X right so what do we
know we know that this whole side this
whole side corresponds to what side on
the smaller triangle well it corresponds
to this side right it's corresponds to
here so let me let me draw it in the
correct color so if we do the orange
this orange corresponds to this right
well this orange corresponds to the
whole thing it corresponds to this whole
line so if we take the big triangle the
big triangle side is not just X right
because that's not the whole side of the
triangle it's X plus 5 so we'd say X
plus 5 that's this whole side right over
X plus 5 over the corresponding side on
the smaller triangle well in the
corresponding side of the smaller
triangle it's just this it's over 5
right is equal to and then we could say
well you know 12 is equal to 12 because
this corresponds to this angle on the
big triangle is equal to 12 over what
over 6 because there's a smaller
triangle over 6 and we could solve for
that this becomes 2 right you get X plus
5 is equal to 10 X is equal to 5 there
you go X is equal to 5 that's all the
time I have for now I hope I helped you
understand similar triangles just a
little bit I'll I'll see you soon